c'était une très bonne idée que la déco
construit ce pied de la tour en grandeur
nature parce qu'il ya une échelle qui
est sûre humaines de fac et donc voilà
la taille de la tour eiffel
même aujourd'hui quand on est repassé
juste en dessous on est saisi yens et
celle qui est pas possible donc d'avoir
cette preuve la noue sur le tournage
c'est clair que ça nous a ça nous a
aidés comme moi je découvre le projet de
flash immédiatement sur son ambition
c'est à dire celle de raconter comme ça
l' aventure de la construction d'un des
monuments les plus connus au monde qui
n'avait jamais été fait au cinéma avec
envie de cinéma assumé de proposer une
grande épopée romanesque d'une grande
histoire d'amour sur fond de
construction de la tour eiffel souvent
on pensait qu'elle est trop de mots
justement dans ces rendez vous amoureux
qui nammour un amour un peu impossible
il faut voir le film et je sais que il y
avait parfois défaut de vouloir trop
dire alors que nous on trouvait que la
beauté des instances et aussi quand il
ya des choses qui se passent sans
forcément formulée sans mot sang comme
dans la vraie vie il croyait on trouve
pas toujours le mot qui décrit la
situation
on est dans l'état je pense que
justement ces silences et la subtilité
entre les personnages et des non-dits
comme vous dites donne ma ce côté intime
et doux très attirant rend attrayant de
l'histoire d'amour rythmiquement je
tenais absolument à avoir des moments en
cinéma qui était très dynamique très en
mouvement
couplé avec des moments où le personnage
était totalement à l'arrêt était
totalement immobile et la mise en scène
du coup prenez un énorme coup de frein
il s'arrêtait aussi d'avoir quelqu'un
qui est conscient du rythme c'est hyper
important mais presque encore plus quand
on fait un film comme ça un peu ce
caractère historique parce que le rythme
dans le cinéma c'est juste que en ayant
la preuve que martin et tous et pour ça
on sait que il va pas d'à coups se
répandre dans quelque chose qui serait
ennuyant ou laborieux où et comme vous
dites toutes les scènes de début cccc
enlevé et en plus il aime filmer et volé
des moments des passages je veux dire il
nous a filmés parfois à notre insu il
est tourné parfois la caméra après
addition pagny c'est génial quand il
s'est incliné face à qui pourrai
d'académique historique d'avoir cette
fraîcheur
[Musique]
romain duris il a amené beaucoup
d'intériorité beaucoup de densité
justement dans ces moments là dans ces
moments de rien c'est un acteur qui
exprime beaucoup de choses ils
fabriquent pas avec des gestes
inappropriés
ils racontent beaucoup de choses dans
son regard dans sa manière tout
simplement d'être ou en mouvement ou
dans un état totalement immobile
c'est un acteur qui en maîtrise absolue
qui son corps et ses déplacements dans
l'espace c'est très agréable parce que
emma ce paradoxe d'être repris à la fois
connues est encore inconnue c'est à dire
que ça pour nous c'était formidable
parce que effectivement parler ses
premières apparitions
voilà qui est cette femme c'est celle
d'autres l'histoire de cette femme qu'on
va me raconter qui est derrière l'
aventure folle de cette construction la
tour eiffel s'est tout de suite un
contrat qu'on passe avec le spectateur
crédible
ce qu'on ne la connais pas encore ou
alors de loin où elle est tellement
différente dans la série n'affiche que
tout d'un coup c'est un nouveau visage
par rapport à d'autres actrices
françaises merveilleuse est talentueuse
dont on connaît beaucoup plus la
filmographie qui aurait forcément
envoyer un signal différent parce que
c'est effectivement quand elle apparaît
dans le film c'est adrian qui est cette
créature